welcome to database deaf talk I'm your
host Minho Scaasi developer advocate for
data studio in this video we'll talk
about community connectors and how you
can use them to fetch your data in a
studio let's get started data studio
helps you to organize access and
understand your information all the
different individuals and businesses
have different needs it is often useful
to have a comprehensive view of their
data you might have data from different
sources social media analytics
advertising etc you might also have
organizational data including sales
finance and human resource your data can
be hosted and available in different
places you might have on-premise private
data for example you might have
marketing information on a bicycle
server on your corporate network you can
have the private data on the cloud maybe
you're using firebase database for your
application you can also be using data
from commercial platforms like Google
Analytics and Google Ads another
interesting use case is using public
datasets a prime example of that is the
bigquery public data set which is
available for everyone to use if you
want to analyze and visualize your data
you'll need to connect to your data in
data studio and that's where connectors
come in data studio provides a number of
connectors for you to connect to your
own data you can connect to a DCP data
source like sheets bigquery cloud sequel
cloud storage and cloud spanner you can
connect to different Google services
like Google Analytics Google Ads search
console YouTube analytics attribution
360 and more there are also connectors
available to connect your own instances
of my sickle and phosphorus but what if
your data is not in any of these sources
that is in somewhere else
well in that case you can use community
connectors community connectors are
custom connectors that you can create
using Apps Script app script is google
scripting language it is a JavaScript
platform on the cloud you can access it
by going to script google.com/apps
script lets you do more with Google
using it you can increase the power of
all these Google applications by using
their API and also by building custom
adults so when you create your own
custom character using Apps Script you
can fetch data from almost any internet
accessible data source you can use Web
API endpoints flat files like CSV JSON
XML databases with JDBC API and also
many Apps Script services in this video
series we will show you step by step how
you can build your own connector once
you've built a community collector you
can obviously use it yourself to bring
in your own data into Data studio now
your coworker sees you using that
connector but thinks that it will be
useful for them they don't have to build
it from scratch again you can just share
your connector with specific users after
a certain time several people in your
organization start using your connector
and it gets really popular you can make
it securely available within your
organization that way anyone in the
organization can use it but the access
and the data remains secure you can also
make your connector available to
everyone and one of the ways you can do
it is by publishing it to the data store
your partner connector gallery there are
more than 100 connectors available that
connect to over 500 data sources you can
try out these partner connectors by
visiting the gallery at data studio
google.com slash data so that was an
overview of community connectors in our
next video we will talk about how
committed collectors work you can always
go to our developer site at
developers.google.com slash data studio
for more information
if you enjoyed this video I can
subscribe to the GCP channel for more
videos like this thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]